that's Jill's problem now the book kind
of sadly
it's like gravity you know I mean
gravity is a real thing Isaac Isaac
Newton was right yeah we went to we went
to Sky Zone and she was jumping but
nothing else was moving around like
what's going on
you have to actually earn a white belt I
thought you start with it
hey welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys
where we are currently Ryan what are we
we're off the Record there it is ladies
and gentlemen and we have Jimmy Zhang in
the building here we go
wow
Wow first off the record with you was
just getting to know you and I feel like
we're going over and we already ran out
of time so we kind of wanted just like
it's getting good it was getting good
we're chopping it up yeah learning how
you help get versions laid where do we
leave off
um nobody mentioned anything about the
porn star yet so we could definitely
bring that one back up
um but how about this I was just talking
to you about like what is your podcast
about you know what I mean yeah uh it's
mainly about like relationship sex
stating uh some of the big ones I had
was
um I had I had a couple on
um Andy and Michelle that I I uh we that
that one did Super well where we just
kind of went into uh what makes a couple
stay together when they're younger and
it's I think it's an interesting time
what's interesting about or like what's
special about Andy and Michelle they got
together young yeah how young like 12.
that's pretty young
yeah uh 20 20 they were 24 when they got
married oh that's what you mean got
together wow married wow yeah yeah and
it just like I don't know I'm also
getting up to that age now where I think
about this
um it was like what what's a ideal time
to get get married yeah right and and
how do I know if this partner is my
partner do you have an ideal time or
even a big picture of it I think I have
ideal time but I don't know if like how
do I know if this person's the one that
that's been kind of on my mind isn't it
crazy how we all reacted like 24 so
young bro and our grandma would have
been like you oh [__] no one's gonna
watch you anymore
I had six children at 24. yeah yeah
different Generations do you have an
idea like like this is I would like my
lady to be like this like these are some
of the things I'll love my lady to have
I think it's it's kind of shifted over
the years
um
like like I I like
the the comfort and the peacefulness of
like having like I guess a traditional
girlfriend who has like a like a similar
routine that doesn't involve a lot of
um
it's like she she she might love just
cleaning cooking and staying at the
house all that traditional gender roles
yeah traditional gender roles right like
a homemaker or something right right
right I think that's very peaceful peace
of mind yeah
um bro that's what I want to do
[Laughter]
hell yeah
but but then on the flip side it's like
it's also cool to see uh maybe something
that that you you've had with Geo which
is like a more
um Power couple type Dynamic where you
guys build
towards like a like a a a a similar goal
and Mission rather than like I'm
building for my mission I just have
wife wifey you know what's interesting
is she wants to go into the traditional
Homemaker like role she don't bake
[__] biscuits and [__] she's just
[__] yeah like that's what she wants to
do now and that's like that's that's
actually like our New Year's resolution
this year wow to pull her off of all
like business and work work related
stuff so she can be like full-time mom
and like I applaud her for this because
like she never really wanted to get into
all of the other social media and
business stuff but she just went into it
like full force did it for over 15 years
and then she really realized that's not
where she gets like satisfaction so to
me I always like call it damn you took
Jiu Jitsu and you got a black belt and
then you go I'm there but I'm really
never gonna do this again versus most
people just dabble in it you know it's
like she really knows she wants to be
like a homemaker she got really lucky
though in the way where um some women
they realized too late or they're single
they're successful in their careers yeah
and they they don't have a kid and they
don't have a husband and so like they're
like pushing you know early 40s late 30s
and then they're like
[__]
I actually want to be like I want a
family like I want and then like you
know
um just you know recently we have like
IVF technology and all this stuff where
people can actually make that work but
then there's so much like it's still new
like the the the
education out there isn't something that
people are taught on it and like you
know and I'm learning this [__] because
we have so many friends that are going
through IVF and because they have
fertility
um problems and [__] but it's like uh
I'm hearing this so much now of like
women who chose that like corporate life
or that success life or like passion
life and then they're going way like I
don't want to just [__] chase goals
and money like that's not what makes me
as a human being and that's like I think
Geo got lucky in that sense where she um
has a family she's built that alongside
and then she has the option to go it's
not me so I'm giving this portion up and
going into being like mother and family
life yeah it was definitely tough
because she was like pretty much had
like three jobs I mean she was sitting
here at JK news
with taika and then still running
barbell so she's like Mommy doing JK and
doing Bible School like we were our
bandwidth was pretty bursting at the
seams so I so now I think after doing
all that she's like I really just want
to
um be at home and take care of taika and
do all that stuff but what's cool is
like all the tools and skills she
learned from all this
like the way she sees it she wants to be
like the CEO of the home which with all
these tools like you can like she's like
I'm gonna set up like like field trips
I'll manage the home finances as if it's
like a has like a balance sheet I'm
gonna like like uh we're trying to build
like rental properties whatever like
she's really gonna try to treat the home
as if it's a business which is pretty
cool because it's like like someone it
takes someone with who has done a
business to be able to understand and
see those things that's true like the
zeros and ones of the Matrix to be able
to apply it but that's what she wants to
do now and you said you're torn between
one or the other well see it's the a
woman who's even like capable of of
doing something like that is it's
someone who's like you know have those I
I guess traits of being proactive I
think that's something I look for um so
like as as I'm kind of like just going
through the motions of life like I'm I'm
I'm kind of learning what I want and
what I like too and because when you're
younger you probably choose a girl based
on how pretty her face is and how round
her boobies are yeah and then maybe if
she has a bouncy butt yeah and then
you're just like oh that is wifey
material right and then later on you're
just kind of like
so I probably shouldn't just choose a
girl based on looks well the first girl
I'm just happy I got a girl
she got some titties
I'm just happy I'm not getting hand jobs
from my best friend anymore and it's a
girl's hand would that be you yeah
smooth I doubt it
trains to hold bars
but I think you know as I as I grow
older uh like as I level up myself I I
also realize I now have the option to
pick a partner that is a lot more uh
like
multi-dimensional right rather than just
yeah nice bouncy butt right right that's
that's good though that's that's still
that's
it it's a pretty high prerequisite I
would say that's Jill's problem now the
but kind of sadly
it's like gravity you know I mean
gravity is a real thing Isaac Isaac
Newton was right
you didn't know till then yeah I didn't
know until like like 39. you see her
she's talking about the effects of
gravity over a long period of time the
theory of gravity that's what yeah we
went through we went to [__] Sky Zone
and she was jumping but nothing else was
moving around like what's going on
[Laughter]
so make sure this diver goes to jail
back to you Jimmy
all right all right so you're stuck in
between traditional gender roles or like
someone that's like I got career goals
right right I I have my own like YouTube
channel I have my own platform I'm like
super talented I could be in front of
the camera I could do all these things
right there with me all right
um so it's like I'm kind of curious as
to like which one is is sustainable for
me oh I got a question for you
um if you were to meet a girl that you
were interested in you guys started
dating and she also had sort of a
similar career where she was trying to
make it as a YouTuber content creator
but her numbers were lower than yours
would you feel like there's some kind of
angle
ex-boyfriends were all content creators
oh
each of them there's a lot of those out
there she had a lower subscriber than
them but she surpassed each one like yo
that's if she actually had a pattern
like that I would be I would be
suspicious yeah I I might I might you
know you know she she could clout Chase
off of me for a little bit but I I want
to see that as a viable long-term oh
okay yeah yeah but you would be open to
like helping
exchanging like yeah oh collabing collab
collaborating covers a lot of angles you
know I mean multi-dimensional angles
I will say I I don't know if you ever
felt this at one point even though
you're totally with a dancer
um but I remember there was a point uh
or there's always conversations that's
funny it's like dancers sometimes
especially in the industry like you you
like date dancers right and then after
you date a couple dances the older you
get eventually like I don't want to be
with the dancer you know what I mean and
what causes that what makes it I think
for us it's maybe more just like the art
this grind oftentimes the artist Grand
doesn't always come with like uh
compliment stability and security right
you know what I'm saying so it's like if
you're already on your Chase
the best balance is actually the
opposite yeah but again it's not it's
not a [__] hard written rule or
anything like that anybody can make it
happen but just generally that's the
dynamic yeah so like you know I wonder
if things even in the same fashion with
certain things like entrepreneurialism
or or content creation specifically as
well I can totally see how it
complements each other you can work with
your partner and like it's just double
the fun and like twice the you know um
output or whatever it is but I could
also understand you know the industry
feeling of like maybe wanting to have
balance in the household right of like
the career and or stability elements is
all that's a yin and yang dude yeah for
all yeah yeah because you have like a
super power couple
um like Layla and Alex from Ozzy you
guys know know them yeah yeah so they're
like super power couple they're running
like a nine figure business
um and she's the CE uh coo she he's the
CEO of their company but you can almost
feel that they're probably they don't
have kids and they don't ever want to
have kids
because they're like on that extreme or
they are that power couple and they just
want to keep crushing it and then so I I
do feel like
um depending on what kind of
relationship you're looking for it it is
like difficult especially in this day
and age where everyone has like the
thing they want to pursue yeah and it
almost feels like you either get this or
you or you get you get this and I think
that's a huge Point too because like at
the end of the day it's it's still
it's still the ladies that gotta bear
the children and stuff like that you
know what I mean so then like if you
ended up wanting somebody that was also
very like proactive your go-getter
entrepreneur there's concert or whatever
that wanted to build her career or her
brand she might not be there for the
kids yeah or or the second you're like
hey I want to have kids maybe she's like
oh but I'm at this point in my career
and then the conversation changed I
actually know a really close friend of
mine who same thing his his wife was
also a dancer you know and they're
they're both in that field and Industry
and they had you know when you're young
you're like this is what I want for my
future but once you actually kind of get
to that point in your life suddenly
things can change because you're like
well [__] I I actually kind of want to
do this or do that we even had Ellen Kim
on here and talking about before she had
her kid too she's like oh I had
questions maybe you know or my my
friends and family are coming to me
saying that they were concerned like
what about your career XYZ and you know
you can still make it and stuff but I do
know that again like my close friend
there's a situation where it's like
suddenly his wife was like I can't do
this and I I can't have kids and that
changed their entire higher relationship
and they got a divorce you know what I'm
saying so they want kids yeah but again
I you know no matter what you gotta also
like kind of sympathize for the woman
too because it's not fair yeah it's just
a different world you know so well
what's more important is what it is like
is is this do you want a life with a
partner because once you get with them
your goals in life and we talked about
this earlier but everything changes
because now you're you're partner team
building your company building you're
thinking about a future for your kids
your dreams will change
so as an individual you might have a you
know this this idea of like you know I'm
gonna be the best boxer in the world or
something right but when you become a
father it might change because you're
like well I don't I don't want to
[__] die in the ring with my kids
watching and you know like it might just
be a different priority and I think that
uh that's the beauty of involving people
into your life and working together
because then now you can have shared
goals like you might throw away one
thing or not throw it away but you might
graduate from wanting that one thing and
then now with the partner you get
excited about maybe having a family
together and moving someplace or like
building a business together and I think
to me instead of creating criteria like
a lot of people believe in like
have a whole list of who you want to
meet which will help you manifest that
or help you find that when they're there
right but I also believe in like
um sometimes you just have chemistry in
the moment you don't know why and then
you can make reason for it later but if
you're a good on the go kind of person
and so are they
then you can kind of adjust because
you're constantly flowing through life
like I don't know anyone that has a
strict plan of five ten years and this
is my method and this is where I'm going
and I have to go this way and if they
are like that I think they should be
with people like that but most people I
think are kind of on the fly in general
they don't plan they meet people and
then they're just like oh I like you
there's something about you I don't know
yeah it's just Primal I like you you
just have nice bouncy butt you know like
whatever and then you stop
physical you're getting into all this
stuff and then you find reasons of like
well maybe we can stay together a little
bit longer because I like your company
and then you kind of go through all this
like these different stages right but at
least for me like when you plan too much
ahead you're planning too much ahead by
yourself so then when you become a
partnership all those plans might not
even come into play because you didn't
even consult with your new team member
so then I don't know I guess that's at
my stage the way I see relationships is
like I don't plan too much ahead because
then that means I'm thinking too much
without my partner there uh I mean you
can dream of like what you want to do
with your life that's I'm not saying
don't do that but I'm saying like
you know you can imagine your family and
all these things and have expectations
but then the person that you will meet
that will change because and sometimes
for the positive because that person you
meet will let you see it in a different
way that you wouldn't have came up with
by yourself
very wise so
um cute face bouncy butt big butt that's
where you're still at right now you I
don't know I don't have to be big it
just
perky perky yeah no I'm past the
existing part guys no no did you say
there was someone that you're sort of
talking to right now or you completely
open slate like nobody uh right right
now I'm just I I just wanna just travel
the world but nobody's stealing your
attention a little bit well it's kind of
that's a good way to put that I think he
wants to taste the flavors of the world
and you should
the buffet is amazing
oh you're gonna like what's out there
boy
it's not so unsexy
you know what the relationship with the
popstar the relationship that you have
with their pops with my dad oh yeah like
let's say you uh meet someone that's
serious
um a lot of times people would be like
well I want to get my dad's approval
like if we're gonna like you know take
the next step do you think that's
something where you're like I would have
to repair it with my dad no you're like
this is my chair this is my girl my life
yeah that's dope yeah yeah yeah
um I don't know it's just it my the
relationship I have with my dad it's
just it's so hard to even like get
through to him I don't know he's just so
stuck in his own old ways I mean yeah my
mom he she's been just
a lot more adaptive to America just you
know she's had more American friends
she's you know learned how to speak I
could speak to my mom now does your dad
have clothes where his hands are like
like this
and he rides around in a wooden box
that's carried by other people yeah
and he puts Saran wrap around his remote
controls that's a new era that's new era
that's like that's like in the in the
1200s bro that's [__] mean dynasty
dad bro would you ever be down to drop
some mollies with their pops and just
pop holy [__] yo whoa
that might be a good video pops [__]
take this and he takes it he's like holy
water yeah
yo I'm not gonna lie he might need that
he might need some Molly yeah to like
break down the barriers
500 bucks straight up cash to get my mom
to smoke weed and just see if that helps
her what is your mom tense
he's a [__] not think the way she
thinks okay Molly water dude that would
be so interesting I invite V down for
that that's a kind of a dope concept
yeah there's a part of that that's like
illegal yeah yeah yeah yeah allegedly
not not with family not a family yeah
Molly in a [__] you know like a
[__]
melty Boba or whatever the funky likes
to drink
grass chili Black Milk Tea
[Laughter]
strong yeah yeah but damn
this one
sneak it in his Ginseng tea bro
oh yeah
can't do it it was that feeling yeah wow
[Music]